meine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das waren unsere freunde der luft auf
musiker des deutschen und der deutschen
bundeswehr furth und keine angst
bekommen wieder aber jetzt ziehen sie
einmal aus mit dem fliegermarsch danke
meine herren und meine dame
entschuldigen
[Musik]
das land
ein großer applaus bitte dass luft war
musik von der deutschen bundeswehr aus
erfurt danke meine herren und meine
beiden damen so meine damen und herren
ein großartiges erster hier auf dem
parkett ein fantastisches orchester dass
sie heute schon sehr oft gehört aber
noch nie gesehen haben unter der
musikalischen leitung von professor
magister oberst bernhard hier ein großer
applaus bitte für das paris der
gardemusik die gardemusik unter der
leitung von magister oder stayfriends
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen großen applaus für dance for dance
und unser wunderbares bald orchester
unter der leitung von minister her eine
der berühmtesten volkers die es gibt in
chur am morgen die die großartige
sängerin haben wir heute schon gesehen
und gehört und jubelten als zwei junge
damen die sie unterrichte denn ildiko
raimondi gibt ihre große kunst auch
weiter und die erste junge dame ist
natürlich wahnsinnig aufgeregt noch nie
aufgetreten vor so großem publikum
sie nennt sie auch liebevoll mein küken
hier kommt extrem jung aus der klasse
meisterklasse von illegalen die bitte
begrüßen sie mit einem jubelt dann geht
es vielleicht mein herr marquis michaela
honauer unser küken das heutige abend
applaus höher
michaela ohne a
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
wenn meine damen und herren das ist der
platz biete für mich eher hohe mauer
michaela auer unser küken des heutigen
abends michaela guten abend war es so
schlimm internet oder wir fragen wie alt
sie sind 21
woher kommen sie aus wie es hat mir
behauptet dankeschön
jetzt weiß ich endlich danke daß dieser
nummer
jetzt weiß ich endlich nach dieser
nummer warum ich nicht verheiratet bin
so würde es mir zu hause sicher auch
geben
ich sehe die herren alle lachen jetzt
aber kommt er der wahre sensation
die junge dame die jetzt kommt heißt es
ist abgesehen davon dass sie bildhübsch
ist eine großartige stimme hat und die
meisterklasse baldiger raimondi in ein
paar monaten beenden wird aus der türkei
weil sie aber gesagt hat und gemeint hat
dass man am besten eine ausbildung im
singen in der großen bundeshauptstadt
wien bekommt ist sie auch noch wien
gekommen
bitte begrüßen sie mit einem
riesenapplaus sk aarhus mit liebe du
himmel auf erden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren es die jsg ich
weiß nicht so wollen wir da was an masse
aber wenn ich diese anschauen und ihre
stimme und was sie können
ich finde sie sind der beste botschafter
ihrer heimat der türkei viel besser als
mancher präsident schön dass sie hier
bei uns in österreich
was haben sie für zukunftspläne ich
träume ich glaube ich bin sehr glücklich
deswegen also wenn wir das also sie
können alles singen was operette zu
bieten hat in österreich oder in
deutschland und ich hoffe dass sie auch
bei uns klar machen wollen oder wollen
sie wieder ganz zurück in ihre heimat
das ist das schönste was es gibt eine
türkin mit einer sensationellen stimme
singt die schönsten österreichische
medien meine damen und herren noch über
einen abgang des verbrauchs wie diese
fantastische dame
[Applaus]
this is called wiener blut dance for
dance mit einem der schönsten walzer es
gibt wieder blut
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das meine damen und herren war wiener
blut mit unserem ballett dance for dance
nachdem wir drei so hervorragende
stimmen haben habe ich jetzt eine
weltpremiere für die drei damen den
immer noch nie gemeinsam mit der
öffentlichkeit gesungen
das ist wirklich tollen nämlich
kammersängerin liga raimondi weitergibt
ihre kunst an ihre beiden schülerinnen
michaela hunger aber und sg al huda sie
gemeinsam im feuersturm der reben freuen
sie sich auf diese drei fantastischen
stimmen generationen meine damen bitter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitte applaus für michaela ohne ski
aluta und kammersänger neely koraimann
de
jetzt bleibt mir nichts über als mit
ihnen zu sprechen habe ich recht gesehen
sie haben während ihrer dienstzeit
alkohol getrunken nein natürlich nicht
sie waren das nicht
ich darf ihnen sagen dass das in live
stream auch in deutschland zu sehen ist
herr major werden sie ein auge zudrücken
sie tun hat dazu wenn er nicht
zurückschicken wir klaudia tanner die
ihnen sicher helfen wird genauso sagt ja
sie haben keine chance mehr die
behaupten es nämlich wirklich dafür sind
irgendwie am namen bieten damit sie
wenigstens gleich ganz geortet sind
christoph strobel krieger herr strobel
bekommen sie aus deutschland aus der
bayerisch farben als erster österreicher
ja fast das heißt fast hallo wir waren
ein super team franz josef und elisabeth
waren die unglücklichsten monarchen der
welt und sie die größten weltstars
geworden
üben sie nur dieses ein instrument aus
oder spielen sie was anderes auch noch
ein hauptsächlich posaune aber es gibt
auch verwandte instrumente die man
natürlich auch bedient also eine
dankeschön das mitgemacht haben und die
zwei damen da ist eine dame ja applaus
hier stellen wir kurz vor von anfang
punkte was haben sie für einen titel
oberstabsfeldwebel oberstabsfeldwebel
das heißt wenn sie um die ecke kommen
müssen die jungs alle direkten
zusammenhang
richtig richtig sehr richtig jetzt suche
ich die andere junge dame noch die es
hier
das schaut nicht so noch
oberstabsfeldwebel stabsfeldwebel
schweres wort genannt wisst ihr was als
janka namenschild sie sind schlicht und
einfach mal vorstellen
ich bin gestern gab die stadt
was haben sie für einen run was haben
sie für einen rang militärisch hauptfeld
des mit die weberin der deutsche
mercedes laut der bibel feldwebel
stadtbildern wie lange sie schon dabei
seit zehn jahren
sie müssen sich nicht überanstrengen mit
dem instrument wenn sie zusammen her
zeigen ja der kollegin daneben hat
sowieso schwerer der ungefähr 100 für so
viel macht ihm so schnell wie so lachten
sie so schmutzig wenn die junge dame
hier steht das ist rein aus
sympathischen gründen
[Applaus]
kennen sie sich näher
darüber wird
wie geht es ihrer brauch wunderbar die
unternehmen ja die frage ist sehr
unangenehm ob alles passt hätte was
sagen sie herr major das hätte man doch
sagen können dass das nicht die zwei
sind die verlinkt sind
es ist es vorbei das hab ich schon
wieder vergessen
also ich möchte dementieren sie kennen
die damen nicht sie haben sie noch nie
gesehen sie haben dann etwas jonathan
den herren auch noch nie gesehen
das letzte mal dass wir zwei deutsche da
hatten hat der mann der dame einen
antrag gemacht ich nehme an das geht
wegen bigamie nicht schwierig aber ihr
seid sehr locker truppe vielleicht
erinnern sie sich meine damen und herren
es hat jetzt vor wenigen tagen große
auch danke fürs gespräch große aufregung
gegeben in österreich weil beim wiener
opernball 2020 ebenfalls ein
traditioneller ball wie der ball die
offiziere zwei frauen gemeinsam weiter
tanzen werden ein riesenwirbel vor fünf
jahren hier auf dieser tanzfläche haben
deutsche und österreichische offizier
weitergetanzt schauen sie wie weit
unsere armeen voraus sind
lieber max holzmann weißen wir könnten
jetzt auch wenn sie ohne neuners noch
man nicht das wäre es übertrieben jetzt
zeigen diese wunderbaren herren und die
zwei damen was sie alles drauf haben und
meine damen und herren halten sie sich
an nicht nur was sie drauf haben sondern
auf welchen instrumenten sie auch
spielen
noch aber ein riesenapplaus unsere musik
aus erfurt danke schiffes mitspielen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
klaus meine damen und herren für diese
wunderbare hocker musikinstrument
garantieren
also ja das ist wirklich es rennt es
gibt ja das angebliche gerücht dass es
dem österreichischen bundesheer schlecht
geht aber dass ihr schon so ohne kohle
seitz dass er jeden hocker nehmen das
musikinstrument das hätte ich nicht
geglaubt
wer ist auf diese idee gekommen ist
einer von ihnen auf diese idee gekommen
schön wäre es schön wird es noch nie
gesehen wie lange machen sie das schon
es mit den hockern zwei wochen war
minister die meisten merken sie können
viele reparieren offenbar anders
deutschland
wie lange machen sie es wirklich schon
zweieinhalb wochen
sie werden gleich ver straften dienste
haben sie schauen assoziiert der
ehrlichste werden wie lange machen sie
das wirklich schon herbert berger rechts
wir machen es seit drei wochen schaut
tief in meine augen
sie machen was vier wochen nein ich bin
der neue hier
ich bin gestern erst dazu gekommen
aber
ich nehme an sie sind alle vier
schlagzeuger ja super ich bin so etwas
anders aus das schlagzeug ein bisschen
ja wie viele instrumente 2 natürlich
alles bescheiden dann bitte ich spiel
jetzt wieder mit oder tragen sie das
jetzt ab wir dürfen wir jetzt wieder
mitspielen im weißen rössl am
wolfgangsee ist das geil meine damen und
herren das sieht man was man aus einem
guten hocker machen kann wenn man schon
das wirklich ein echter rocker ist ja
gott aber die herrschaften können hier
nicht nur auf hockern trommeln sondern
sie wagen sich über eines der
berühmtesten österreichische musikstücke
nämlich im weißen rössl am wolfgangsee
sie dürfen sie sollen mitsingen und
mitklatschen hier noch einmal unsere
freunde vom musikkorps aus erfurt danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und mit wien bleibt wien verabschieden
sich freunde aus erfurt danke dass sie
bei uns in wien waren wir freuen uns auf
ein wiedersehen wien bleibt wien das
musiker erfurt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke schön herr 54 herrenlose
instrumente stehen jetzt auf dem parkett
vielleicht hat mein applaus an unsere
wunderbaren kameraleute auch die hier
heute das video machen für das
bundesheer
[Applaus]
ich bitte noch einmal
die dame zum ziel noch mehr und seinen
plastischen noch einmal den scheck über
7.000 56 euro wer versuche es noch
einmal kommen sie bitte zu mir
jetzt sehe ich entziehen sie wir haben
200 ist 295 die damen hatte ich hier
jetzt noch mehr vollendet eine sind sie
bitte wir haben wieder eine damen karte
und die zwar die damen karte 1000 25 10
meine damen und herren die nachfolgenden
sendungen werden sich um zwei stunden
verspäten
diese nummer geben wir jetzt zum ausgang
in unser büro
denn die sind nämlich draußen jetzt hört
oder sieht hören werden sie mich nicht
übersehen werden sie mich sie haben
gewonnen
gut wenn nicht verfällt das lose
automatische reaktion moderatorin not
danke schön draußen bleibt liegen
meine damen und herren ich daraufhin
noch ein paar hinweise geben was sie
heute hier noch zu sehen bekommen werden
so tanzt österreicher und die guten
seiten zeigen ihnen und erklären ihren
österreichische volkstänze
ernst musik - um 2.30 erleben sie
krieger kranz mit seiner großartigen las
vegas show eher zufälliger going to do
listen schönen las vegas show
jetzt gibt es dann gleich die quadri
unter der leitung professor schäfer
elmayer der von seinem jungen
assistenten vertreten wird professor
magister oberst bernhard her ist sie da
ist jetzt am zuge
meine damen und herren gewann davor
alliance of the world changing cultural
meine damen und herren heute wieder der
beweis dass armeen auch gut sind wenn
sie sich völker verbinden mit kunst und
kultur wie auch abschieden uns von ihnen
hoffen dass sie nächstes jahr dabei sind
und heute haben wir wieder gesehen dass
die österreichische armee nicht nur
perfekt ist wenn es darum geht die
bevölkerung zu sichern oder aber in
großen katastrophen einzuschreiten nein
sie ist auch völkerverbindend und hat
kulturell viel drauf nirgends so
weitergehen guten abend und haben sie
noch eine schöne nacht auf wiedersehen
[Applaus]
ich habe gerade erfahren
schuldiger
ich habe gerade aufbauen
ich habe gerade erfahren liebe liebe
liebe liebe liebe liebe regie jan ich
habe gerade erfahren dass er einen
einstieg noch haben wir diese zwei
fantastische musiker haben von vorhin es
tut mir leid das habe ich nicht gewusst
aber das müssen sie sich jetzt anhören
guten abend wir hören jetzt etwas von
beethoven ein wunderbares beethoven ja
was werden sie uns bringen fünfter
sinfonie von bento wetter werden von
daniel piller bitte meine damen genießen
sie bitte diese beiden jungen herren
welchen rang haben sie gefreut
ein gefreiter sich auch zwei gefreite
und die burschen können derartig spielen
das sie sicherlich begeistert mitmachen
werden zusammen mit unserem orchester
beethovens fünfte sinfonie
schauen sie sich das an
[Musik]
meine damen und herren die brüder tag
und daniel piller vierfache weltmeister
der kammermusik und vier herren unsere
wunderbaren orchester
jetzt sind wieder sie dran bitte er
stürmer sie die tanzfläche
denn in wenigen minuten beginnt hier
eine der großen tragödien jedes weil es
die sogenannte mitternachts batterie die
heißt heute bei uns nicht mitten aus
kadrii sondern ein uhr quadri und die
tanzschule elmayer wird sie hier wieder
ausrichten für sie
und sowas her mit unserem wunderbaren
daten